much so in light with what bianca said
across nevada there have been
problems getting the vaccine to the
public and the rollout has been
even harder for teachers here in the
valleys they're trying to get the
medicine as well
hector mejia live this morning with a
look at how ccsd and local health
officials
are trying to meet the demand hector
good morning good morning john and
teachers tell us they've been getting
mixed messages about who is eligible and
when some even told us
they were able to make an appointment
online only to get turned away once they
arrived on the site
we talked with the clark county
education association last week
ccsd's largest teachers union well they
told us they were working with clark
county to make appointments available
for teachers
starting this week the goal was to make
1 000 daily appointments
available for educators the southern
nevada health district has a section
specifically for
teachers on its website that's how some
were able to make an appointment
however we are told that system likely
crashed and created even more confusion
we talked with one ccisd teacher who was
able to get her vaccine
last week if we don't
get our vaccines it's not
safe for us to be back in the buildings
many many educators have either
health conditions there's there's
different
situations that we all face many have
other people living in our homes that
are at risk
ccsd says it's still working to come up
with a process and timeline for every
educator
on friday the district said that only
medical professionals or law enforcement
officers
within the district were provided with
the chance to make an appointment
and the district says it's been sending
teachers updates on a regular basis and
they're asking for more patients
as they figure things out live this
morning hector mejia
8 news now